it's great to welcome back to the
program today Jonathan hight who is a
social psychologist and professor at New
York University's Stern School of
Business he's the author of multiple New
York Times bestsellers including the
righteous mind the newer book
co-authored with Greg lukianov
the coddling of the American mind is
just now available in paperback Jonathan
so great to have you back on thanks
David it's great to be back so we've
been talking a lot on the program about
the sort of media cycles related to kind
of modern politics now in particular as
the election is starting to ramp up and
how sort of at a core structural level
the way in which corporate media cover
politics perpetuates a lot of the
polarization that you've been writing
about for a long time do you see it that
way today oh my goodness yes so you know
I think of human beings as this amazing
species that that came down out of out
of the trees and evolved for life in
small groups you know loops of 50 to 150
people that are constantly or not
constantly but often at war with each
other or at least having violent
intergroup conflicts and we and we
evolved to circle around rocks and trees
and other things make them sacred and
then have small scale religion that's
human nature now somehow or other we
escaped from that we built these
gigantic societies that were a feudal
originally very hierarchical and then
very recently we built these amazing
secular it get relatively egalitarian
open prosperous democracies really quite
amazing what we've done but we're still
the same tribal religious creatures that
we've always been and the modern media
ecosystem beginning with cable TV and
then moving on to the internet and
social media has gotten more and more
effective at breaking us up into smaller
groups feeding us with very different
facts we live in different worlds worlds
in which we we hate the people in the
other worlds and we increasingly are
willing to take action against them so
yes it's very frightening one of the
criticisms that sometimes levied when
one starts to make a
more general we live in different worlds
and have different facts sort of
analysis which is not a wrong analysis
but one of the criticisms that sometimes
comes up is yes people live in these
self-perpetuating algorithmic
echo-chamber sort of worlds with
different facts but there is still some
truth there are things that are true and
things that are not true and there needs
to be more of a maybe reckoning some
would say which separates the fact that
there is a degree of polarization in
which people are just in echo chambers
and at the same time there are there is
truth and falsity at the same time as
they're not oh well I certainly agree
that there is truth or falsity but I
don't see that as a as a critique or
criticism of the view that we now live
in separate worlds rather I would say
the truth has always been hard to find
even about medical issues people didn't
notice that if you know doctors wash
their hands their patients don't die and
even when that was pointed out to them
they didn't believe it so it's very hard
to find the truth we have universities
we have an academic system to ferret it
out and we also have journalists who are
supposed to do that so we have
adaptations to help us find the truth
but man has it gotten harder in the last
5 or 10 years because of social media
almost anything that you take as a fact
now there are people on the other side
if it has a political valence there
people on the other side who who are
certain and have evidence that you're
wrong and I because I'm in the center
and I write about these things I get
emails from people on all sides so
whatever the scandal whether it's Brett
Kavanaugh whether it's the Amazon
rainforest burning people send me things
to show oh look the other side is crazy
you know so so no I I do agree that
there's truth that's why I'm a
researcher and a professor but I am
despairing of our ability as a country
to find truth on important matters ever
again so what is the in is there a set
of I don't know a set of steps so to
speak for someone who wants to determine
that truth because as you say there's a
there's a significant difference between
supply-side economics is a positive or
negative influence on our neck on our
economy for example and here
the reality of what we are doing to the
planet because of industrialization and
the burning of fossil fuels I see those
as distinctly different sorts of
arguments question one is do you agree
that those are different types of
arguments and then the maybe more
important part is what is the process
you can recommend to people to arrive at
the truth about either or both of those
issues well it's true that there are
certain propositions that are more
easily testable and so on the question
is the planet warming but there are some
people on the right who deny that but as
far as I can tell there are very few so
that I think is widely accepted as a
fact and has been for a long time not by
all next question are human beings
responsible for the warming well then
some more people on the right will drop
off and say they used to say no it's
sunspots I don't know if they still say
that so there are certain things that
are fact and I certainly think it's
established that human activity is the
major cause of the rise but then the
question is anything else that happens
so let's just take the the fires in the
Amazon that people are understandably
worried about well if you're on the left
you're told that this is that this the
Amazon is the lungs of the world makes
20% of our oxygen but I read from people
on the right and in the center that
biologists say that that's not true I
know I haven't dug into it I don't know
I'm just saying that
and they're a counterpoint well it's not
just that there is a counterpoint it's
that we if you're a partisan if you're
on a team whatever comes your way you
don't you say hmm is it true you say oh
my god
this confirms the things that I believe
most desperately this confirms why
they're so evil and you have lots of
people helping you confirm that it's
called confirmation bias that we don't
say well what's the evidence on both
sides we say can I can I take this as
evidence that my enemies are evil we
look for that evidence and we always
find it and the internet just google it
you'll know it you'll find it online so
yeah there are facts but I think I'm
again I am just despairing of our
ability to find them you have talked
about the sort of evolutionary
advantages that some of the dynamics
that we observe in humans have had at
prior times and maybe even still have
today one of the things I've been
studying is this concept of the
narcissism of small differences and I'm
I'm curious if we imagine a world where
imagine that the Wright convinced the
left to come to their side on global
warming on abortion on gay met whatever
right let's say the left said you know
what you've convinced us you're right
would there not be a reification within
the new sort of pillars of discussion
wherein there would be a new out group
within the right that would be on the
left of what is left so to speak and you
would have the same exact degree of
polarization disagreement and sort of
alternate fact worlds that you describe
yes in general I think that's true I
mean we certainly have made a lot of
moral progress each side has convinced
the other a few things the direction of
history has been more in the progressive
direction in that you know do should
women have the right to vote should
women have equal opportunity or equal
access to everything there's not any
serious debate or doubt over that so
then we move on where the left says well
okay now what we need is equal
representation that women should be 50%
of say all the you know all this all the
engineers and computer programmers and
the right says no we should have equal
opportunity I wouldn't exactly call it
the narcissism of small differences
those are major and important
philosophical questions what counts as
the standard for fair Society but yes I
think your general point is that
progress progress material progress or
moral progress will never end our our
furious debates we will always find
things to argue about something as
simple as do we need that is the cause
of our problems that we've lost touch
with the old ways and the wisdom of our
ancestors or is the problem that we are
not advancing fast enough and we need to
tear down what we've inherited and build
something new that's the fundamental
question between progressives and
conservatives is the political system
that we have well-suited to adjudicate
some of these bigger questions
that you've mentioned today and also
that you talked about in the book or is
it fundamentally a system that either by
design or by outcome by side effect is
not going to possibly resolve those
disagreements yeah I would never say not
possibly because the future is very long
and we've been through bad times before
so you know 50 hundred years from now I
have no idea where we'll be my friend
Steven Pinker is probably right that
things will be a lot better certainly on
material issues will be a lot better but
are there specifically some design flaws
our problems with our system that make
us worse or more gridlocked more
dysfunctional than many other
democracies I think the answer is yes so
the worst number of political parties to
have in a country is one that's really
really bad but the second course number
is two because our minds are really
finely tuned to do us versus them and
there's even research showing that if
you break people up into groups of into
three or four different groups you don't
get the kind of split you don't get the
ferocity of the split that you get when
you break people up into two groups so
two is a we have two parties I wish we
didn't it wasn't the design of the
founders but it emerged even over the
question of whether ratify the
Constitution they were the Federalists
and the anti-federalists our system is
designed to make it easy to block to
block bad ideas to block whims and
passions of the public so our system is
designed to be of autocracy and then
various kinds of political corruption
have amplified that any any group that
is strongly like the NRA any group that
really wants to stop something has a lot
of ways they can stop it
whereas if the majority favor something
it's very hard for them to actually push
it into law what are the particular
issues that you see as at least in the
short to medium term not solvable as a
result of that structure so I think well
I think almost all of our big issues are
going to be very hard to solve so let's
just take climate change for one so I
think the left has been correct about
the nature of the problem but the right
has been correct that trying to solve it
by getting big
mint agreements is hopeless we're not
gonna get China and India to solve
things because they agree you know to
reduce their pollution because of some
agreement that their government signed
Emmanuel macron tried to do that he had
riots he tried to have more
environmentally minded policies he had
riots in France so countries aren't
gonna do that that way I think is fairly
lies failure I think the right is
correct and here what I mean is
especially the libertarian or
free-market right that these problems
are massive and the only way we're gonna
decarbonize is if individual consumers
and companies conclude that it's cheaper
and better for them to use carbon free
sources and so I think if we leave it to
a OC and the green New Deal which
basically takes let's tries to approach
climate change by importing all the
things that the left-most wants that
approach the green New Deal has some
some good things in it but it guarantees
that people on the right are going to
fight it tooth and nail I mean we have
to have a high minimum wage to fight
carbon yes oh okay but let's go back
just one 1/2 a step maybe I actually
sort of sympathize with the idea that I
believe the fact bear out that in the
long term it is actually cheaper more
efficient than therefore more profitable
to get away from fossil fuels but I
think the the missing step in the
libertarian approaches unless there is
an intermediary force that pushes before
we get to the long term in the short
term it's much easier not to do it and I
think that that's where the libertarian
analysis that you made Falls a little
bit short Oh totally agree so you know
if I were king or if I could advise or
if there was a government capable of
acting on advice I would say that that
ultimately the heavy lifting is going to
be done by market forces and if we could
have massive federal expenditure into
getting really cheap solar wind and
nuclear nuclear it really has to be part
of the problem if we're serious about
this massive government expenditure to
to get to those points 10 or 20 years
earlier than we would without subsidies
yes it's urgent that we do it
so I'm not a partisan I'm not a
conservative a progressive or
libertarian I think all three have have
insights to go back to your early
question what should one do if they want
to find the truth I'll tell you what
worked for me I was on the Left when I
started writing the righteous mind my
goal was to help the Democrats win more
elections and I committed myself to
understanding conservatives and
libertarians and what I discovered is
that if you look at the best writing you
get lots of great ideas there are lots
of really smart interesting people on
all sides whereas if you get the worst
writing if you're on Twitter and you
just are experienced people the most
extreme versions you'll think well
they're stupid and evil so I think we do
need we do need as individuals and in a
policy process we do need people to
propose ideas other people to say no
that won't work because of X here's a
better way and you have to have a
process by which the best ideas win
universities are supposed to do that
that's sort of the idea of the Hegelian
dialectic in a sense but the the concern
I have with it is that when some of the
ideas being proposed are outrageous
you're sort of pulling the mean in a
direction that is not particularly
productive I mean that's my concern with
that that the idea you're proposing I
think I see what you're saying that the
John Stuart Mill didn't use the phrase
marketplace of ideas but it's not a bad
metaphor and so if in a real marketplace
you know the real marketplaces work
really well but if you had a marketplace
which you had a lot of people trying to
manipulate the market and you have lobby
groups and industry groups putting out
fake reports yeah that's a market
failure so that's why we need quality
control and that's why universities I
think are or should be our best hope for
finding the truth now I've been very
concerned that in the social sciences
which is what we're really talking about
here we really need the social sciences
to work right to solve these political
and social problems in the social
sciences they've always leaned left
which is not a problem as long as there
are a few people real researchers who
are committed to the Academy to say well
wait a second here's some counter
evidence we used to have that now that
we've shifted much further to one side
this is happening across society
in a polarization cycle lots of
institutions are purifying so my fear is
that social science research is not as
reliable as it would be if we had more
viewpoint diversity when you have
serious professors who are committed to
the research process you don't get crazy
ideas put it that that comes from lobby
groups and non non professionals so
you're not literally saying every crazy
idea should be part of what is
considered the serious discussion but
that we should have a system in place
that will sort of filter so that the
ideas that are being taken seriously
have passed some kind of either explicit
or implicit vetting of sorts yes that's
right
I would never say we need all ideas I
would never even say we need all
perspectives what I would say is we have
to really look out for orthodoxy if we
have any group that is responsible for
finding the truth which is subject to
orthodoxy which means that if someone
finds counter truth they will be shamed
or expelled then we cannot rely on the
conclusions of this group we've been
speaking with Jonathan Hite he is a
social psychologist the paperback
version of the coddling of the American
mind co-authored with Greg lukianov is
now available Jonathan so great to speak
to you as always my pleasure David